a lot of people's reactions when we're
told no we're gonna go basically the
north pole or on mountain bikes where
are you bringing ice tires you know
because most people think of the north
pole they're like okay it's even cooler
the whole cell they don't really realize
that there's an Arctic desert are out
there my name is Darren berrecloth I'm
from Vancouver Island British Columbia
and I'm a professional mountain lake
free rider
free-riding is all about picking your
own line and being free to interpret the
mountains in any way that you see fit
thinking about starting on the horizon
right there it'll be like a drop onto a
rock slab the reason that we chose axel
Heiberg island was because the mines
were massive it trumped anything yet we
ever written before in terms of height
and just sheer scale boys boys epic time
one of the hardest parts about that
whole trip was just as its remoteness
and how far it was from civilization if
something goes wrong we were about 12
hours away in the best-case scenario
from any Hospital afar or that serious
help
the lands cake up in the High Arctic was
just it was breathtaking standing at the
top of the line just soaking it all in
it's it's a pretty rad feeling one thing
that's amazing about my Viking is the
fact that you can take it that you can
climb mountains with it we can descend
mountains with it you can travel long
distances with it and you can stuff it
every box and flying it around the world
to go up to the High Arctic 400 miles
south of the North Pole and ride my
bikes it's a pretty amazing thing to do
and check that off the bucket list for
sure